freunde herzlich willkommen zu diesem
video ich bin hier heute nicht im
gewohnten umfeld sondern in der wg von
meiner freundin ihr erinnert euch
vielleicht und ich es heute einen tag
mit meiner freundin genau was sie will
und lara darf deshalb entscheiden was
wir essen gehen was ich ihr kochen muss
was ich hier besorgen soll wie kennst
vielleicht manchmal braucht man so diese
eine sache von diesem einen laden und
auch das ist heute möglich deshalb wenn
wir den ganzen spiels mal umdrehen ich
auch nicht nein
auch geil dann fangen wir an mit dem
frühstück es gibt berater brote und
frisch gepressten orangensaft sollen wir
heute so ein bisschen blogs teil auch
treibt ein bisschen blogs als erstes
machen wir berater brote und einen
frisch gepressten orangensaft
[Musik]
was auf jeden fall nicht zum ersten mal
ist das so ein ding hast du öfter strich
gemacht auf der job das ist glaube ich
liebe es frühstück ich würde mal so ich
mache es natürlich nicht zuerst bei soll
ich habe schon häufig und
spender ist es ganz häufig dass hier und
das heißt jetzt kurz 73
45 minuten bis
das öl dazu
denken wir jetzt um den frisch
gepressten orangensaft landab
branchenweit ihren
[Musik]
perfekten glas alter denkt ich bin da um
die brote sind auf fertignahrung
was bedeutet break wissen
[Gelächter]
zeit für unsere tomaten
vorletzten knusprig geworden das ist der
perfekte zeit und wenn sie so leicht
aufgerissen sind weil dann haben sich so
die tomaten sagt no job findet tomate
war schmeckt direkt zu herz haben so
vollmundig und plattenwege
wenn wir die brot ein bisschen kühl ist
wird man mit diesem geräusch hier
belohnt und jetzt müssen wir nur noch
belegen
[Musik]
sehen sie nicht wunderschön geworden wir
brauchen mal einen teller
super einfach das frühstück auszulassen
machen wenn er sich das wünscht bekommt
sie sagt ari ein girl tara das ist ja
für gutachten hier ist ein schritt der
krise cluster for a portrait spiel
hoffentlich zu seiner zufriedenheit was
ist
das ist
auch gut ich bin wirklich gespannt was
du später noch sofort weil im prinzip
kannst du mich heute auch auseinander
nehme ich meine jetzt nicht so kaviar
oder so aber ich habe eine andere idee
stecken jeden frühstück laden macht das
einfach genauso in jeder wird kaufen
nach wie ich sehe hast du auch gegessen
drei mal
drei mal nachbestellen
lieblingsstück von
m von m
aber keine sorge emma ist die firma die
dieses wunderbare bett hier gemacht hat
noch bis vor kurzem hatte hier ein
anderes bett stehen und wirklich dieses
bett hier ist zehnmal bequemer und wir
starten zehn mal besser in diesem bett
deshalb schon mal an der stelle danke
schön an im schlaf denn er ist nicht nur
für mich wichtig oder wichtig sondern
für alle menschen denn wir verbringen
ein drittel unseres lebens im bett ohne
guten schlaf statten wir alle nicht gut
in den tag viele machen sich aber
überhaupt gar keine gedanken über ihren
schlaf und wie sie ihn verbessern können
und hier kommt eben immer ins spiel denn
emma bietet neben boxspringbetten auch
matratzen topper kissen bettdecke und
viele andere produkte haben klare habe
ich das immer onebox spring web bestellt
weil sie schon immer eins haben wollte
und das wirklich sehr sehr bequem ist
und das super cool ist der bezug hier
hinten ist wechselbar man kann ihn auch
austauschen wenn man beispielsweise eine
wand grünen streicht kann man sich auch
ein grünes bett machen und das ist super
easy und anpassbar den körper kann man
wenden er hat eine weiche und eine harte
seite und ich muss wirklich sagen ich
schlafe ihr einfach sehr sehr gut also
wir haben paar nächte schon im bett
gepennt und das ist negativ jetzt ist
die frage was macht emma besonders und
wie könnt ihr davon profitieren punkt 1
die lieferung der matratze ist kostenlos
und die können 100 tage lang kostenlos
probeschlafen punkt 2 ab 10 jahre
garantie auf den matratzen kennen und
die bezüge sind abnehmbar und waschbar
und für euch habe ich noch was ganz
besonderes mit dem komma max spart ihr
zusätzliche fünf prozent auf alle
rabattaktion die sowieso schon bei emma
auf der website laufen und es lohnt sich
da mal vorbeizuschauen weil da könnt ihr
wirklich spart also klickt auf den
ersten blick in der video beschreibung
und holt euch guten start nach hause ich
sage das nicht so kann es wirklich
empfehlen das ist ein sehr gutes bett
vielen dank an emma dass sie mich
unterstützen und weiter geht es mit
einem tag essen was lara möchte lari
umgezogen max umgezogen 100 sachen dabei
ist geht los oder
brechen auf wir fangen es in die
innenstadt dann dafür hat sie einen tag
alter ausdrucken
gute scores
[Musik]
klar wie was haben wir gerade gemacht in
die schweiz gefahren weil du dir im café
gewünscht
dass ein programm manager sohn der stadt
das schmerzt mir natürlich in meinem
barista her zuletzt von ihren kaffee
bekommen können aber der luft war ich
sehe mich tatsächlich gleich auf jeden
fall mit was lästigem ok mit so was wie
science lab und bürger so eine pizza ok
und dann hab ich noch eine sache auf dem
programm auf jeden fall die ich noch nie
gegessen habe ich aber unbedingt mal
essen möchte habe ich schon gegessen ja
ich bin gespannt muss ich noch mal
kochen
als nächstes steht
[Musik]
das haben wir
sind gerade bei edeka ich glaube jetzt
heißt er kann ja nicht dass folgendes
richtig meisten körpers bei schmidts
auch in minsk arbeit lahr ii ist
experten dazu sagen toms auf meisten
bezüglich ich habe schon zugesagt ich
glaube ich habe mehr bock aber auch
gerade ist sie jetzt ja sowieso und
currywurst pommes mit
sogar cent leicht auch nie oder passt
auch zu so einem wundervollen
sommerlichen tag von der schöne
currywurst pommes oder das leichte ist
zwischen
[Musik]
einfach reingezogen genau der ruf der
currywurst können so aus dem laden wurde
aber ich fühle
in der sonne haben übrigens 23 grad
deswegen muss das wetter auch gestern
ausgerückt werden wir müssen es jetzt
irgendwann die sonne balla
schon verkaufen achtung riechen aber
glücklos haben was
können wir machen ich war auf dem stand
betrinken und schnellen
flasche die hat auch eine idee gehabt
[Gelächter]
ganz keine auszulösen das land jetzt
zebra bin wirklich gespannt ob du es
mögen das dem ordentlich zitrone auf
jeden fall gerade am anfang dann
mal was von der muschel dabei meint also
man muss es mögen das ist 17 wie schlug
nordseewasser
nun petit
ich bin echt gespannt was zu sagen
fühlst du mit dem meerwasser ist einfach
so als würdest du seinem schwimmenden so
einfach das machen
und du solltest aber keine frische wird
das wirklich damit zitrone und so kühl
abweisen so ist das schon sehr frisch
aber es ist wirklich was besonderes
also ich glaube dass es so ein geschmack
den musste erst lernen und dann kannst
du auch so gut für außer beurteilen
daran so richtig spaß an aber ich glaube
außer dass ein klassisches mindestens 30
dringt dann ab auf dann kannst du es
check aber
und gute appetizer oder
einfach der ganztags aber nur von der
appetizer
weiter wir sind jetzt bei karmann
gekommen unser letzter stopp ich weiß ja
noch nicht aber vielleicht letzter stopp
bei unserer heutigen food reife mag ich
voll gerne hier waren aber noch nie in
einem video hier deshalb sehr gut das
ist ausgewertet was hast du dir bestellt
lassen
was auch sehr krass hier sind die rahmen
haben wir nicht bestellt aber weil wir
uns ja sonst nix beenden nachdem sagen
wir mal ein paar juni die rede aber
nicht nur ich sondern wir hat mich also
die topetage schreiben lag nur den
exklusiven scheiß ich habe auch das
ereignis und maßgeblich beteiligt war an
der bestellung von mirabal und auf
wir haben bei juni leicht flambiert ich
glaube das ist endspurt hat sich der ton
angemessen dass ihr
sport
mit einem hattrick hat einigen was ist
es das unkritische schlimmste
ist der kleine schon
jetzt kommt nur sarah man
das reihen haben schon verstehen hermann
test ist
auch mit abos auch mit liebe geschnitten
also ich muss euch sagen dass eine sehr
sehr gute auswahl getroffen den ganzen
tag über als ultra lecker warst du musst
dir vorgestellt hast ja noch was noch
hat sie nicht mit der geplanten
freunde das war es auf jeden fall vom
video ich bin jetzt auf den weg nach
berlin in geheimer mission ihr werdet
früher oder später erfahren worum es
geht dank fürs zuschauen bis dahin macht
es gut und job